bonsoir ça y est merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france sont bien
d'écouter les propos d' emmanuel macron
c'est inacceptable cette inégalité vous
partager ce sentiment du président
français oui je partage ce sentiment
mais le problème aussi au lieu à ce
sentiment c'est que qui peut agir dans
ce sens parce que le tente on prend les
gouvernements une bonne partie de
gouvernement qui sont eux-mêmes
désemparé n'arrivant pas à avoir les
doses qu'il leur faudrait pour la
population
donc du coup les autres des pays
africains qui eux ne bougent pas ça
devient un problème et comme on dit
souvent la mecque il donnait toujours en
dessous de celle qui reçoit ça c'est que
c'est assez difficile puisque les pays
africains n'ont pas contribué à 100 la
solution serait que les hommes
politiques c'est à dire les décideurs
aient la force d'agir
or il me semble que dans le contexte
actuel ils sont un peu lié ils n'ont pas
toutes les mains libres
donc pour ça mais sinon je suis
entièrement d'accord avec son dû
c'est une forme de démagogie entre
guillemets de la part du président mais
kron qui effectivement fait face à des
difficultés puisqu'ils n'auraient
pénurie caractérisée de doses de vaccins
en europe également et qui d'une
certaine manière semble s'offusquer
qu'il n'y ait pas assez de vaccins en
afrique de la démagogie vous interpréter
ça comment quand vous l'entendez le
président français quand je l'entends je
te dire que c'est de la démagogie parce
que bon il le semble se battre aussi
pour son pays pour avoir ce qu'il faut
mais de l'autre côté en tant que
président français il ce parti de haut
niveau mondial d'une part par et allons
par exemple nations unies de l'ouest où
il parle aussi au nom d'une population
beaucoup plus large que la population
africaine
donc de ce fait il est dans son rôle de
constater que effectivement il ya une
zone de la planète qui se reste qui se
trouve être un désert en termes de
vaccins il est dans son rôle de le
constater
mais maintenant ce que je dis aussi
c'est que ce rôle là et ce double euros
le pilat à disposition il devrait
l'utiliser pour influencer pour les
organismes pour que cela puisse
se réparer mais ce que je dis comme
constat c'est que quand vous prenez les
big pharmas à toute l'industrie
pharmaceutique y sont pas prêts du tout
a lâché quelque chose là qui ils sont
plus manipulés par la bourse qui
s'affolent par le financier qui fait que
le vaccin qui il ya un des ministres y
d'ailleurs qu'ils allaient proposer que
ça pourrait être un bien public et ce
vaccin qui a été financée en partie par
les fonds publics
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui parler dans
le cerf un bien public
c'est impossible donc ça ce sont des
choses qui ne peuvent venir que par les
autorités qui ne peut venir que par des
dirigeants des présidents comme macro
comme un glas merkel ou tous les autres
il dans le film y compris le russe mais
parce que c'est tout ceci là qui sont
des voix pourtant qu'il peut faire en
sorte que cela puisse se passer
on imagine que l'union africaine a pensé
à cette question est ce que l'union
africaine a su parler d'une voix pour
tenter d'approcher tous ses laboratoires
comment elle procède l'union africaine
dans ce domaine au niveau de l'union
africaine ils ont le centre de contrôle
des maladies ecdc qui est basée à addis
abeba au siège même de l'union africaine
qui collabore étroitement avec les
différents ministères de la santé et en
particulier avec l'om est ce aussi donc
mais ce sont des institutions qui n'ont
pas à eux de l'argent à prendre pour
aller acheter est donné ce sont des
institutions un peu comme le ms qui sont
sous les ordres
il exécute les ordres des chefs d'état
et pour exécuter ses ordres et leur faut
de l'argent pour pour la mise en oeuvre
et c'est adrien est également donnée par
les différents états donc ils peuvent
parler des filles n'ont pas les moyens
d'agir
ils pourront toujours continuer de
parler donc au niveau de l'hygiène
africains leur couleur politique a été
dès le départ de pouvoir avoir un
minimum de vaccins pour chacun des pays
africains et de pouvoir les étudier le
problème qui se pose aussi c'est que il
ne faut pas que tout le temps la
décision ce soit du top down c'est à
dire dans le dissident haut et puis on
impose les pays africains ils ont une
expertise évidente et je pense que le
problème c'est que les niveaux des
autorités ils ont été très désemparés ça
a laissé les médecins africains
travailler
et donc il faut la laisser travailler il
faut la leaf et définir leurs besoins
comme ici on l'a fait on a classifié par
exemple les populations est aujourd'hui
en sursis qui meurent le plus ce sont
les personnes les plus âgées ont tous
commencé par vaccinés à ce niveau là
donc chaque pays pourrait définir ses
besoins pour septembre de population
pour la première vague est ensuite pu
prévoir les seconds zag en fonction du
taux de létalité décès qui se passe dans
chaque pays ils ont eu beaucoup une
bonne expertise et il faudra aussi on
travaille maintenant à leur donner une
sorte d' expertise locale parce que tout
le temps attendre que le nord fabriqués
à mais nous que le nord d'essayer de
caisse qui est bien pour eux alors qu'il
ya une expertise locale qu'on peut
utiliser
nous sommes dans une pandémie qui montre
que nous sommes tous dans la même case
que nous sommes tous sous le même le
même arbre donc ça veut dire que il faut
que les moyens de production aussi soit
un peu d'espacé pour qu'elle ait aussi
puisque c'est à dire en maintenant
matière même de vaccins qui quittent a
promis c'est un accès localement pour
que ça puisse être utilisable ce qui m'a
surpris thème du lion d'un million de
matthew est débattue aujourd'hui
peut-être il y en aura deux perdu qu'on
pourra pas conserver comprend pas
transporter et il ya un grand manque de
fonds actions qui vont commencer à bâtir
à circuler parce que les gens vont les
fabriquer puis pouvoir avoir de l'argent
clairement quel est l'état des forces en
présence ce nid j'ose dire
on imagine que c'est assez compliqué
selon les pays mais
il y a quand même des campagnes qui ont
bel et bien débuté avec succès des
campagnes qui ont débuté avec chips et
surtout au maroc par exemple où ils en
ont fait ils ont fait des vaccinations
et l'afrique du sud 5 cas particulier
parce que l'afrique du sud c'est
vraiment comme on le dit un état
arc-en-ciel fava delà du développement
le plus performant comme en europe ici à
la pauvreté la plus extrême donc c'est
une étape essentielle c'est pas toujours
évident de le prendre comme référence
bain par exemple au sénégal ils ont ils
vont commencer aussi il ya eu le malawi
qui est l'incarnation et de la major la
majorité d'entre eux utilisent le lac
chinois sinovac
d'autres comme le maroc la tunisie ont
également commandé des doses avec chez
les russes donc en fait celle ci qui ont
un peu plus de moyens qui ont déjà
commandé leur propre doses pour
commencer la vaccination
les autres ont peu de contacts mais
n'ont pas encore reçu ou comment dire
une performante à commander d'abord de
l'action alors le mot location hier en
urgence par l'om est d'astra zeneca
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour pour
l'afrique
alors pour la slick la bonne nouvelle ce
serait un bastien facilement maniable je
pense qu'on a tous très emballés pour
beaucoup de choses à chercher des
vaccins qui vont jusqu'à 95 100 % tous
les vaccins qu'on a utilisées
jusqu'aujourd'hui
dès qu'il atteint 60 % d'efficacité on
est content on a toujours dit qu'ils
étaient jusque là alors vouloir un
vaccin qui fait du 95 94 pour ça et sans
avoir les moyens de l'utiliser dans les
conditions définies par le fabricant
c'est une utopie ça sera finalement ça
sera finalement criminelle puisqu'on va
injecter de l'eau à des gens en disant
qu'ils font vacciner donc l'afrique
devrait s'orienter vers des vaccins qui
peuvent manipuler c'est à dire dont ils
ont les moyens de conservation et toute
la logistique qui va avec
pour permettre de vacciner le nombre de
personnes qui vont de vue de vacciner
merci beaucoup autre chose il est
plusieurs vaccins mais chaque pays
pourra faire son choix en fonction de
ses moyens
merci beaucoup ça y est nous avons
arrêté
non direct sur rt france